and here come the Clippers Paul when it
rains it pours in transition
bad news plays with the finish
Paul has it a distance in traffic to
DeAndre Jordan what a show by DJ Chris
Paul off the window to Blake
the fans are abuzz at Staples Center I
think that's like a dunk contest oh
that's a choreographed plate
acrobatics two great finishes if this is
[Applause]
Griffen from Chris Paul
that's a tonne join the other way Wow
you
but jets are having fun the players are
having fun and the broadcaster's are
having fun do the little bit havin fun
sickles are up by 41
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and Chris is looking over at the fencing
yeah guys kudos to God whoever designed
and I'm sure he did but they executed it
perfectly here comes Chris Paul the love
I want to see it again this could be a
goodish
foreplay that's as good as anybody
anywhere congratu tonight
why did I try and jump for that one what
up at you boy Adam left go do you like
that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report